[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute ist uns nach kleinen teigtaschen
also porzer auf türkisch und wir machen
die jetzt heute vegetarisch und wie so
eine kleine rolle
ich habe mir gleich auch samira und
eller zum helfen ich werde jetzt aber
zuerst mal einen hefeteig zubereitet mit
etwas joghurt das macht den hefeteig
einfach super weich und zart und auch
saftig bringen doch so eine leichte
säure mit rein und die zutaten habe ich
eigentlich immer zu hause
ich denke er auch und wir starten jetzt
auch direkt also dafür nehme ich einen
halben würfel hefe einen teelöffel
zucker 100 gramm lauwarmes wasser
hier habe ich 500 gramm mehl da könnt
ihr weizen oder dinkelmehl nehmen
ein eiweiß 200 gramm naturjoghurt das
ist der dreieinhalb prozentige einen ht
löffel salz und 100 gramm weiche butter
also zuerst einmal nehme ich jetzt die
hefe und löst sie hier im warmen wasser
auf aber ich glaube ich mache das hier
gleich und das großen rührschüssel 120
verschüttete ich dazu warmes wasser rein
ihr verein bröseln den zucker auch mit
rein geben und kurz verrühren
gerne auch schon ein bisschen mehl den
vortrag lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz auf
gehen also abdecken und so zehn minuten
etwa 10 bis 20 minuten stehen lassen bis
das nicht vergrößert hat ich mache das
jetzt hier direkt mit hitze dann geht es
nämlich schneller
am besten so beachtung 20 grad da
vermehrt sich die hefe nämlich optimal
dann geht's weiter hier mit dem hefeteig
beim hefeteig immer darauf achten dass
salz und fett zum schluss dran kommt
also jetzt auch schön so ist das mehl
dazugeben dann das eiweiß
denn salz und fett hindern einfach die
hebamme auf gehen daher immer zum
schluss dazu geben
der joghurt noch dazu geben und den gebe
ich jetzt auch nicht direkt auf die hefe
sondern eher in die mischung damit die
hefe einfach zum schluss erst mit dem
set in kontakt
ich will jetzt auch schon mal anders als
davor
und dann die mutter
und jetzt lasse ich den hefeteig die top
10 minuten kneten damit er richtig schön
geschmeidig wird mit der hand können
auch gerne kneten hat auch immer etwas
meditatives und beruhigendes aber ich
mache jetzt so denn dann kann ich in der
zwischenzeit aufräumen
[Musik]
so sieht der hefeteig jetzt wunderbar
aus und erklärt auch nicht wir sehen
können
er ist einfach richtig wunderschön reich
geworden
ein kleines bisschen zu weit geworden
hast du noch ganz wenig mehr einknicken
jetzt hat auch eine schöne konsistenz
[Musik]
jetzt warum ich dann einfach zu einer
schönen kugel
was sie dann abgedeckt für 30 bis 60
minuten aufgeben
wir sind sich richtig schön verdoppelt
hat
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist jetzt perfekt
aufgegangen jetzt geht es an die füllung
ich mache jetzt eine füllung aus hirten
käse frischkäse etwas petersilie und
pfeffer und ich muss jetzt erstmal den
porree klein schneiden
da nehme ich jetzt hier die dunklen
blätter erst mal weg und den wasche ich
immer ganz gerne nach dem schneiden wird
euch einfach zu den dunkelgrünen und
wegnehmen
die könnt ihr wunderbar für eine
gemüsebrühe zum beispiel verwenden
und jetzt den rest einfach fein
schneiden
ich hätte so schön weil man da so von
den natürlichen verlauf drin hat schon
schön
ambri ambri effekte beziehen eine
salatschleuder und auch schon wasser
drin
und jetzt kann ich sie nämlich rein
geben und schön durch schleudern und so
entfernte den kompletten sand einfach
laut focus schon immer sehr sehr sandig
noch ganz vorsichtig 10
damit kein brunnen entsteht jetzt einmal
fest dass sie dann habe ich hier wieder
springt jetzt kurz abgießen und dann
noch mal richtig trocken schleudern
da nehme ich jetzt hier ein käse rädchen
und zerbröselt somit der hand
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt der föderation die
füllung hat meine mama immer gemacht
wenn sie rosenberg gemacht hat also mit
sehr dünnen luft blättern damit
petersilie dazu die habe ich jetzt aus
dem gefrierfach
da hab ich nämlich immer gehackter
petersilie auf vorrat wenn ich im sommer
einfach ganz viel habe und dann fragen
befasst schlecht wird da noch etwas
pfeffer dazugeben
das war immer so frisch gemacht und
frischkäse
[Musik]
gut einfach kurz alles vermischen
jetzt teile ich den teig in 16 nationen
ein
entweder macht ihr das so dann direkt
erst vierteln dann nochmal vierteln
jedes viertel oder mit funktionären
trockner internet schön
dann hin zu kleinen kugeln formen
[Musik]
hier kommt kriegt noch nicht stürzen
hast du hände gewaschen ganz gründlich
hatte ich mal kurz die band
[Musik]
ich habe nur gehört hatte ich mal kurz
die kugeln fertig ich mag es auch so
du kannst nicht schon besser als mancher
erwachsene gleich aber erst brauchen wir
eine kugel platz aber auch dazu ein
bisschen ein bisschen mehr
und dann so von außen nach innen und
eine schöne kugel genau so wie es aber
gemacht hat als auch wie beim
weinblätter wickeln
nehmt ihr jetzt eine teig kugel guck dir
mir zu und wir machen jetzt alle gleich
okay und dann haben wir gleich porsche
panamera
ella hast du mir so sicher
sonst stehen gucken sie will mir kraft
zeigen dass sie aus dem augenblick geht
es sieht schon was ich mache ja und
jetzt kommt einfach mit dem eis
portionierte füllung rein und wirklich
wie beim wein trauben wickeln ich hier
bisschen verteilen und dann hier oben
einschlagen geller und an den rand
einschlagen und einwickeln sah man nur
mit teig so und dann sieht es aus wie so
eine frühlingsrolle okay also komm jetzt
machen wir das alle zusammen super
einfach ein schöner crash durch den
ausbau starb
nach oben wollen jetzt den rand
einschlagen
warum aber kommt mir jetzt gar nicht so
viel mädel nehmen okay das ist jetzt zu
viel mehr
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier ein eigelb das
berührt jetzt mit zwei esslöffeln sahne
ihr könnt aber auch mitnehmen zum
beispiel und dann wären die teilchen
gestrichen
[Musik]
es gibt hier noch schön sesam und
schwarzkümmel drauf und dann kommen sie
schon eben den backofen
ich stelle sie jetzt in den kalten
backofen und heizt dann den ofen erst
aus und dann kann nämlich die aufgezeigt
direkt als aufheizzeit genutzt werden
ansonsten können das jetzt noch mal
abdeckung und dann im heißen ofen backen
aber ich finde eigentlich mal ganz gut
im alter ofen hat das gebäck noch zeit
zum aufgehen
[Musik]
auch schön ich bin murat und das ist die
schönste strecke der welt
[Gelächter]
was hast du gegen blumen shirts 30 ich
denke immer mich an das ding jetzt t
shirts ich immer das was sich schon auf
tischdecken drucken können ok dann gehen
wir weiter und zwar geht es eigentlich
gar nicht um die tischdecken und zwar es
geht um dass hier das nennt sich fortan
und ich denke da muss ich mir das
gefallen lassen
du kannst dir rauswerfen aber das haus
gehört mir da hast du ein problem
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
porsche bringt ich weiß nur
unterstreicht nicht borgia wie heißt es
vor sharjah ist immer öfter und so und
der sportler klein handlich aus der hand
essen
ich bin ein forscher klein handlich
es ist ein problem dass keinerlei
ständig an oder wie weit liegen damit
vielleicht den so genial ist da könnte
ich bin 20 journalisten
aber ganz ehrlich die möchte warum ist
wirklich so warm essen nach einem tag
sind sie auch gut nach dem dritten tag
auch nach dem tag sind wir schon noch
groß also ich finds ja ganz heiß auf den
ofen so jetzt am besten am nächsten tag
sind sie auch noch gut aber da erwerben
ich sie lieber auf dem toast zu deinem
backofen oder luftdicht verschließen ja
auf jeden fall ob es noch voll lecker
muslime fleisch sein schatz ja aber
vielleicht auch kubys geschmückt und mir
fehlt jetzt noch ein bisschen schmoren
rezept gemacht wo er spielen kann ist ja
gerade das so nicht kommen doch mir
fehlt jetzt noch ein bisschen chili ich
will jetzt auch chili rein machen aber
ich habe es nicht wegen den kindern dass
die gleich mit essen können und er unser
merapi haben mitgemacht und zwar soll
ich dir von ella ausrichten wollte kurz
damit seien dann hat er lag am 8 nach
exakt das ist der papa hat warum denn
mein schatz dann hat sie gesagt der ist
klein und dick und dann hat sie den
nächsten gemacht und das ist der ist
auch dick bis 17
laut gelacht weil er ganz so das ist
doch und das ist der könig liebt es so
eigentlich habe ich ja auch nicht das
höchste was gefährlich ist weil man ist
es dann so aus der hand und es tun ist
und ist und deswegen werden na ja ich
mache so ein tor zu welt passt perfekt
nummer setzt man auf die terrasse essen
forscher mit dem kind werden und ich
glaube es gibt keinen menschen der
bildes nicht mal ich glaube auch ich
kann's nicht vorstellen und früher als
ich noch ein kindergarten hinter schule
hat meine mama immer so sachen gebacken
potter oder bedeckt und haben sich alle
gefreut wenn meine mama mit zum ausdruck
haben denn türkische mamas bringen immer
was mit dem ausflug das bringt immer was
mit auch beim fußballverein alle alle
anderen lieben man merkt noch gar nicht
schneller so ist ja
viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis zum
nächsten mal
ich bin mir dem türkischen satz sagt
damen haben beim immobilienkauf wenn ich
gehe
tschüss macht's gut
[Musik]